- [Kelly] I wanna remind everyone
of something that you said
the last time I did see you.
So let's just see this tape.
- What is one thing you
like to do post-COVID?
- I have a list.
(Kelly chuckles)
- A fun thing? A fun thing?
- Yes.
- I don't know,
maybe go have a martini
and some french fries.
- Yes!
(Jill laughs)
I knew I loved you.
(audience cheering and applauding)
If I didn't already like
you, that brought you over.
I just like to make people
feel comfortable here.
So for you, I thought I'd go ahead
and bring out some
martinis and some fries.
(audience cheering)
Look at you carrying that
so carefully, Justin.
- Oh my goodness!
- Okay, you take one, I'll take one.
- Okay.
- Fine, fine.
I don't know if we're supposed
to move it from the plate
but I did 'cause I gotta get there Justin,
you put that drink real far from me.
(everyone laughs)
It's like he is there like
they know I don't drink much
so they're like, "Sip on it."
- [Jill] Here we are day drinking. Uh-oh.
- Yeah, day drinking.
Cheers!
- Cheers!
- Oh and cheers because,
you're soon to have a wedding
also in the White House.
- Yeah.
So yes I'm having a we--
We are having a wedding.
It's my granddaughter,
my oldest granddaughter.
(audience applauding)
Thank you.
- Just so you know, that's real.
- [Jill] Mm!
Oh yes, it is.
- Yes it is.
I took a sip and I was like,
"It ain't watered down, ma'am."
(Jill laughs)
We're just gonna set that right there.
I didn't get a ton of sleep.
So that's exciting at
the White House, wow.
- It is. You know, it's so special.
I have four granddaughters, two grandsons
and I think that's one of the
most special relationships
that I have in my life is to be a nana.
And it's just so special to
watch, her name is Naomi,
to see her really planning her
wedding, making her choices
becoming, you know,
just coming into her own
and she's just so beautiful.
So I can't wait 'til all
of you see her as a bride.
- Oh, and what a cool venue for a wedding.
(Jill laughs)
- [Jill] Yeah.
- Yeah.